the distribution of resting pulse rates
of all students at santa maria high
school was approximately normal with
mean of 80 beats per minute and standard
deviation of nine beats per minute
the school nurse plans to provide
additional screening to students whose
resting pulse rates are in the top 30
percent of the students who are tested
what is the minimum resting pulse rate
at that school for students who will
receive additional screening round to
the nearest whole number if you feel
like you know how to tackle this i
encourage you to pause this video and
try to work it out
all right now let's work this out
together
they're telling us that the distribution
of resting pulse rates are approximately
normal so we could use a normal
distribution and they tell us several
things about this normal distribution
they tell us that the mean is 80 beats
per minute so that is the mean right
over there and they tell us that the
standard deviation is nine beats per
minute so
on this normal distribution we have one
standard deviation
above the mean two standard deviations
above the mean so this distance right
over here is 9 so this would be 89 this
one right over here would be 98
and you could also go standard
deviations below the mean this right
over here would be 71 this would be 62
but what we're concerned about is the
top 30 percent because that is who is
going to be tested so there's going to
be some value here some threshold
let's say it is right over here
that if you are in that if you are at
that score
you have reached the minimum threshold
to get a additional screening you are in
the top 30 percent
so that means that this area right over
here is going to be 30
or
0.3
so what we can do we can use a z table
to say for what z score is 70 of the
distribution less than that
and then we can take that z score and
use the mean and the standard deviation
to come up with an actual value
in previous examples we started with the
z-score and we're looking for the
percentage this time we're looking for
the percentage we want it to be at least
70 percent and then come up with the
corresponding z-score
so let's see immediately when we look at
this and we are to the right of the mean
and so we're going to have a positive
z-score so we're starting at 50 here we
definitely want to get this 67
68 69
we're getting close and on our table
this is the lowest z-score that gets us
across that 70
threshold it's at 0.7019
so it definitely crosses the threshold
and so that is a z-score of 0.53
0.52 is too little so we need a z score
of 0.53
let's write that down
0.53
right over there and we just now have to
figure out what value gives us a z-score
of 0.53
well this just means 0.53 standard
deviations above the mean
so to get the value we would take our
mean and we would add
0.5
standard deviation so 0.53
times 9 and this will get us
0.53
times 9
is equal to 4.77
plus
80 is equal to 84.77
84.77 and they want us to round to the
nearest whole number so we will just
round to 85 beats per minute so that's
the threshold if you have that resting
heartbeat then the school nurse is going
to give you some additional screening
you are in the top 30 percent of
students who are tested